ta clique est au taquet sur ma vidéo
[ __ ] j'y retourne sa speedo se trouve
sur facebook ça fait chier pas de madoff
et sa part trouvé sur ce logiciel qui
limite notre tête en version un petit
peu [ __ ] laveur par exemple regarder
tous les avatars que ya maintenant à
tous les tester un parent parce que j'ai
envie ça me fait plaisir à ça me fait
plaisir de vous retrouver au avoir voire
parfois repower ag chier dans ton aux
croquettes ça se fait des photos
d'identité dont ont permis de conduire à
8,5 à elle elle est aussi l est pas
naturel est un peu bizarre
bonjour je vous mets ma mèche j'ai
l'europe autant d'émoi boyer à prévoir
ce pas à le guen soul et la guadeloupe
où joue un loup à un morgen monga alors
lui voyez par exemple celle inverse du
chat il alerte tout le temps gentil je
sais que vous avez envie de me caresser
balesi ans le dragon le dragon bordel
sévriens desmond salut je suis mag
j'ai mis mon cul sur un trésor pendant
si longtemps que maintenant j'ai le cul
doré j'ai fait un bide parfois je peux
et je suis intelligent ok voilà comment
vont elles tomber au c1 chiba ouanna qui
tarde plus tôt il a gardé le morgen tous
pourris de thaler je vous invite à
prendre le chien le plus mignon du monde
ou est ce que je veux dire ou pas à thé
de mentir je sais très bien que tous les
humains ou un petit faible pour le coup
des animaux alors c'est vous qui nous
mangent et nous les [ __ ] burger
mais saviez vous qu'on peut être d'un
coup pis la bnr je vois plus rien mais
sur ces caches médias je me suis un bug
je suis un burger innocent ne mange pas
sinon tu fais une erreur on sent au
voilà en fait des vannes oc m2 alors ça
c'est perso j'ai jamais fait c'est un
dlc spécial sortie pour halloween
barrois mâché une momie et 1 but en fait
on dirait pas mais il faut je suis allé
aux toilettes et
à tanger un message fait attention à toi
mon fils m'a ouais mais c'est un peu
trop tard pour dire ça ben j'avais rien
à faire à part jouer avec le pécule un
vrai bon jour à tout ça crème hydratante
vous dites je ne connais pas trop mais
j'ai pas l'air aussi vieille que ça ok
mais caché mon chapeau et jeunesse n'est
pas c'est juste un oeil pour par est
diabolique
j'ai vu une vidéo
tu comptes le nom de points noirs que
j'ai sur le net j'ai pas eu la chance
d'avoir toute cette industrie la crème
que vous vous avez les jeunes dentifrice
vous dit bonsoir à tous effectivement je
connais bien le gel on peut en parler et
un truc que j'ai failli vous savez pas
faire c'est simple pourtant c'est caché
ma bouche de la monnaie ah ouais moi
j'étais juste une citrouille t'as vu ea
et on m'a enchanté je suis un photo
terrifiant et je peux être aussi très
très bio à moi mon histoire ça rime ex
de astérix obélix
à quand j'étais petit je suis tombé dans
du papier cellophane voilà salut à tous
d'aller bien bah écoutez moi me compare
souvent olaf mais en version du pauvre
tom budget pourtant généralement les
spéciales quoi je suis là où on m'a fait
sous le soleil
ça m'emmerde je vous le dis je me plains
olaf depuis que tu existes ma vie est un
calvaire
si je te vois je tends broche direct
avec ma branche jetant branche
et rouler au la créature la plus fidèle
du monde bouge je suis comme la mecque
du tout début mais version féminin avec
du rose bonjour je suis une petite
poupée
il fume habitants venus parfois au genou
dans son résultat et lucas viendra t sa
blague parce qu'en fait j'ai pas fermer
les yeux dans le jeu salut effectivement
je ressemble beaucoup à leurs burgers
chez son frère
sauf que moi j'ai pas du tout pu
l'arrêter parce que les gens disent que
j'ai mangé un enfant mais tu crois toi
pour être malade pour faire ça alors moi
une fois l élevage et j'ai violé à un
canard bah ouais aux mondiaux chez
morgan stanley tu vas faire un squeeze
la meilleure coupe que moi au on l'a vu
c'est le most de dredd out mon pote à
elle a un côté un petit peu ça va t-il
se trouve peut-être son petit nez tout
doux bas mais bon ça m'intéresse pas de
faire peur tu as peur devant jumbo mon
grand tu crois vraiment qu'il a besoin
de moi
oui bonjour je suis qu'à white
je suis kawaii mais un poubelle mais je
suis calme why must have de cet appel
les gens se demandent souvent ce qu'il
ya sous le bonnet des cheveux poteau a
tué deux âges mon enfant j'ai juste eu
et à sa barbe on n'a pas grand chose à
dire sur moi et c'est [ __ ] d'oiseaux
qui vient tous les choses dans quelque
chose te plaît non cherche pas à
arracher un petit truc bizarre tu sais
avant je me faisais tout le temps à gacé
et depuis que j'ai une épée et benjamin
gas plus tu la vois là elle est là qu
est ce que tu la vois oui moi les gens
soient qu'on a fait le tour de fès riga
cette façon la plus ces cas n'hésitez
pas et les vidéos que d'habitude dans
vos freins sont sur le jeu dans un an a
laissé le rituel une vidéo par année sur
ce je suis quand même impressionné de
voir à quel point en temps réel il
arrive à reproduire ce que tu fais sur
sur le perso marin mersenne regard des
instants très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo portez-vous correctement tout le
monde pis